- [Voiceover] Which of the
following expressions is
equivalent to 7k,
7k minus, minus,
the product of k plus one
and 2k plus two.
All right, so this is
going to be 7k minus,
7k minus the product of
k plus one
and 2k plus two?
And so let's see to kind
of expand it all out
we will want to multiply
these two expressions,
so let's do that first, so
this is going to be 7k minus,
and then let's just multiply this out.
You're going to have k times 2k,
which is 2k squared,
k times two which is going to be plus 2k.
Then one times 2k,
which is going to give us another 2k.
And then one times two, which
is going to give us plus two.
And we want to be careful.
We want to put a parenthesis out front
'cause we're going to
subtract all of this stuff
right over here.
So this is going to be the same thing as
7k minus, and then in
parentheses we have 2k squared.
We can add 2k plus 2k to get 4k plus
4k plus two.
One way to think about it
is we can distribute this
negative sign or you could even do this as
minus one times all of this.
And so this is going
to be the same thing as
7k minus 2k squared,
so minus 2k squared,
2k squared minus 4k,
minus 4k,
and then minus two,
minus two.
And let's see so if we write
the highest degree term first,
if we write this term, do
this in a different color.
If we were to write
this term first, you get
negative 2k squared, that's
our highest degree term.
And actually immediately
when you look at the choices
only one of these start
with negative 2k squared
has negative two as a coefficient
on the k squared term,
so we already know that that
one's going to be the choice
but let's just confirm it.
So it's negative 2k squared,
and then we could add,
we could add 7k and negative 4k.
Those we're going to add seven minus four,
sum then is going to be three of that.
So it's going to be plus
3k which is what we see
right over there.
And then finally you have this minus two.
Minus two which is exactly
what we see in this
first choice up here.